the student loan art program is a unique
opportunity for students here at mit to
actually borrow work
from our student loan collection that
they can take home with them for the
year
and hang in their dorm room or their
apartment
the student loan art program began by
the generous donation of catherine
stratton and the program officially
began in 1977
where students got to take real art to
their dorms
as a museum our main role is to put a
person in front of an art object so this
program does that beautifully
but it goes further in that the student
actually gets to be a collector and to
live with a piece of art for one year
i first heard about the student art
program
through my an email that was sent to my
dorm building
and some people from my building were
going so i just joined them
like my first choice was taken before
but i was just
excited to get art taken back to my dorm
room
the first time a student finds out about
the student loan art program they're
incredibly surprised because they
they're thinking
this is an engineering school not an art
school and
first time they participate they're
incredibly overwhelmed because we have
over
550 pieces of art and had to choose one
filling out a questionnaire to give us a
little bit of feedback about the program
no i don't mind at all
our class found out about the loan art
program
from an email that was sent out over
campus and
i think half a dozen of us came down and
filled out the lottery slips
and four out of the six of us wanted the
warhol painting
and i got it which was very exciting for
me but
not so exciting for them and it was
great because i've had this blank space
on a wall
in my apartment for about two years and
so for at least the past two semesters
it's been
filled by this neon colored warhol
painting
the process is basically in a nutshell
that every fall we hang an exhibition in
our galleries
right around the start of the year where
it's up for a few weeks students come
and they see all of the artwork
installed salon style in our galleries
and then they have
the opportunity to submit their lottery
choices
and after the exhibition closes we go
through all of those selections
about 500 students get work of their
choice
this is my 10th year on campus but first
time getting art i've heard about in the
past but
never actually got around to checking it
out but i'm glad i did
this year we wanted to decorate our lab
with art
so um we had a spare wall and so give us
my lab base to come over with me and
pull together and get our chances higher
to get a piece for it
mit is certainly all about pushing
boundaries and asking questions and i
think we at the list
try to do the same thing with our
exhibition program and with our
collections programs which the student
loan program is one of i think
it's the right place for a program like
this because it's not
it's not expected it's not typical it's
really
stepping out of the normal role of what
a museum collection is and pushing it to
a new and exciting level in a way that
the mit community can really engage with
it and live with it and
they connect with it in a way that
wouldn't otherwise be possible